hey man tyrell about to come out here
right now you're gonna watch that ladies
watch this watch this thing yo tyrell yo
what up lauren hey man you want to play
front hand backhand
i don't know that game man it's easy
dawg all you got to do is stay front
hand on the backhand
all right front hand
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's still my move right i choose
backhand this time
really back hand
oh
oh look tom i'm sorry but i ain't sorry
you know what i mean i mean you asked
for it
i mean you literally asked for it
right hand what no why you want a hip
got it i figured it out front hand
no backhand backhand look look dude hey
if you want me slap you across the face
backhand i'll do it okay don't think i
won't do it but but you know that i'm
with you right i mean there ain't no
game called front hand backhand
oh oh doc
yeah i get it i get it all right all
right all right
as soon as i get good at front-hand
backhand you wanna stop playing
play what man i made it up so i can
smack you in the face i'm about to smack
you in the face
as soon as it's my turn right hand there
ain't no turns
because it ain't no game you ain't got
no game backhand
right hand look i don't know if you
[ __ ] me at this point or what
but i don't want to smack it no more
where you going then okay forfeit
forfeit
i win i went from him back okay
me and you me and you me and you
hmm backhand
you